so i think like we all have this
collective
mental health issue um again for
a disease we don't have a name for yet
it could be like i
don't have one like it's not a good
short name but like being afraid of a
future or
don't feeling at home in the world
anymore so the outcome is though
that we become extremely tribal because
we
try to find um like refuge or like a
home or like stability in a world of
permanent instability and it's not going
to change i mean
the world in 15 years or 10 years will
be so different
meaning never ever we had we have a
change which was happening so quickly
so and we so we resort in this tribalism
which practically makes
also every now coming back to korvik
every rational discussion
obsolete meaning we completely lost the
ability i think to be
in the middle of something
i'm dave rubin and we're mixing it up a
bit today we're gonna
shift from politics hallelujah we're
gonna be talking about
crypto about longevity and of course
about magic mushrooms
joining me is the founder of iperon
investment group a board member of the
hayek institute
and the founder of the anger meyer
policy and innovation forum
christian angermeier welcome to the
reuben report hi dave
uh pleasure to be here it's good to be
with you you know you were one of like
10 people that i would occasionally
check in with
in the last year and a half to make some
sense of the world and talk about covet
and lockdowns and
science and fact and all that stuff so
i'm going to just start you broadly here
where are we at in the world right now
where are we
well uh we let's start there i'm
vaccinated so i'm
pro vaccination if that is this it seems
still to be a big debate in the us
always when i post something i get a lot
of hate and love and whatever
but in generally like if we we discussed
it before like if we take it one level
higher
one of my my um my ideas or my fuses
that sort of the whole world is
kind of going into or is already in a
mental health crisis meaning it's really
the mental health crisis in terms of
really like
what we at the moment define as mental
health crisis like depression anxiety
addictions or all of
opioid addiction like all of these
numbers are
skyrocketing but i think we have
way more issues we as a
sort of planet or humanity is going
through mentally
which we have not defined yet
as a as a real disease so my so if you
talk to so many people they
feel literally and they can't even
express it because there is no word for
it like
yeah but like like that some somehow i
think
the majority of people feels that the
world is going in a direction
which a doesn't make sense for them so
they can't understand a lot of things
anymore
and b they subconsciously and that's
even worse
no there might be no place for them
in the world let's say we the tech elite
is building so i'm always when i
i have these literally every time i
whenever we do a new investment and i'm
telling my friends like we just did a
investment in a brain computer interface
company
and so my vision is and i'm super
excited about it that in 10 years 15
years all of us gonna have brain
implants
yeah brain computer implants and
and then we can sort of do things like
from
telepathy to communicating without any
device
being the sky is the limit what you can
do if our brain is directly into a
computer
i think it's fascinating and always when
i talk to friends of mine
i realize how deeply terrifying that is
for them
yeah and it's just one example so what
i'm thinking is that i'm coming back why
are you saying that in terms of cobit
so so i'm thinking like again the world
it makes less and less sense for people
at the same time they
they don't feel sort of at home where
they see they don't have a place
and that frightens them yeah and fear
unfortunately brings out the worst in us
yeah so and fear and trauma
is also one of the underlying root cases
for mental health issues
so so i think like we all have this
collective
mental health issue um again for
a disease we don't have a name for yet
it could be like i
don't have one like it's not a good uh
short name but like being afraid of a
future
or don't feeling at home in the world
anymore so the outcome is though
that we become extremely tribal because
we
try to find um like refuge or like a
home or like stability in a world of
permanent unstability and it's not going
to change
the world in 15 years or 10 years will
be
so different meaning never ever we had
we have a change which was happening so
quickly so and we so we resort in this
tribalism
which practically makes also every now
coming back to corvit
every rational discussion obsolete
meaning
we completely lost the ability i think
to be in the middle of something like
it's always like
in here when we had all these
discussions like both sides like the
in america the republicans or the right
wing the left wing like
yeah it's insane and i think there is a
more
underlying reason which is the one i
just described yeah so that's why i
wanted to have you on because i've been
talking about on the show for a while
that it seems like we're at the end of
one world and there's a new world on the
horizon but but people are worried about
it we know about all the mental health
stuff
but you were kind of in the psychedelic
game before
all of this was happening like you
you've been thinking about how do we
make
people happier and less
depressed and with less anxiety and all
that stuff for for quite some time when
did you get interested in that
um i got interested i can tell you
exactly in 2014
when i had my first own magic mushroom
trip
which was in a country where it's legal
which was
which country was that that was holland
you know it was actually on a really a
tiny island it's called kanwan in the
caribbean
yeah so it's legal or not classified in
most countries in the caribbean latin
america
and actually in the netherlands like
that's the uh the interesting part
and so and by the way
because i maybe i mean i come to this in
a point that i think
psychedelics should be taken in a
medical context or at least with a guide
so i had a very good
shaman doing it with me but like uh
just for the ones watching now and
saying jesus he's a druggie like
i always was extremely comfortable to
talk about it because
i am the least druggy person you ever
would have met like i have never drank
alcohol ever in my whole life
i have never smoked a cigarette never
smoked a joint actually never did
anything else like i drank
um coffee when i was 28 for the first
time and
christian and not coffee oh now i like
coffee is okay now but what i want to
say so i came very virgin
to that whole thing and then it was
hands down
the single most meaningful and important
and life enriching thing i've ever done
in my whole life full stop nothing
really comes close
and i have to say i was already a very
happy person
yeah so and immediately after that i was
like okay
if it can do this to me yeah a happy
person
i can totally see why in the 50s
this was and 60s actually some
psychedelics
were already legal in a medical setting
against depression whatever but back
then depression was not a big thing so i
was like
it must be that i was very sure actually
people would work on it now because this
was so
powerful and then actually for two years
i was looking around are there any
companies i can invest in
there weren't and then i did it myself
right so what's that like when you're
like all right i'm gonna be the magic
mushroom guy and i should tell you i
i've done magic mushrooms many times and
it's b
it's been a while but i've always loved
doing it i never had a bad effect i
wasn't
depressed after anything if anything
it's exactly what you're saying it sort
of
elevates the good stuff but but sort of
what i think is interesting about you
also
is that you're you're basically but i
don't want to put words in your mouth
you're basically politically a
conservative
and i think it's kind of there's like
this dichotomy between wait a minute
he's a conservative
but also he's the magic mushroom guy i
sort of say that's what the new sort of
conservative thing
is so can you talk a little bit about
that and then how you went ahead and
said okay we're going to make this into
a business
all right so first of all bernie i mean
totally fine but sorry i actually would
say i'm rational like and
i'm i'm no and it's like i think one of
the big problems
is already that i think we're still
using terms
which don't fit in our time anymore
there should be no left and right
because
left and right i always tell my friends
who are like in germany and the social
democrats are like you were
there i tell my friends look you should
have gone home in the 80s because
you won yeah you really if a hundred
years back
there were a real issue for the working
class yeah
so then someone you reached everything
you should have reinvented yourself
finally
but that's another topic finding
actually there would be a place for
real social in a positive
i know socialist in english always have
these negative we call it social
democrats like
center socialist because i think never
ever then
in the last 60 years then today the
working class has a real issue because
their jobs gonna vanish all of them
hundred percent
yeah yeah this is what tucker politician
i would take
that as my thing how can i help um
the real working class how can i how can
how can we create
and this comes back to my worry about
the mental health state
we have to create a world where we
all have a place because let me take one
analogy which is not a nice one
but to sort of paint a negative picture
because we had all of that like 100 if i
so i love history
like and if you if you if you i
searched for like a time which is sort
of similar to ours i know history never
repeats but rhymes like
so but like if you go in the time 1850
to 1910 1915 there are so many parallels
the elites were completely tech savvy
you had julverenda
the author he was writing actually about
going to the moon
about flying to the stars about going uh
undersea you had the
people forget that it was the time of
the the world fair in paris actually so
the eiffel tower was built as a symbol
of technological uh innovation so there
was the biggest elevator in the eiffel
tower
you had all these amazing books writing
about uh
actually future like fantasy but it
became real like actually
anyway so you had these enormous
optimism you had berlin by the way being
an incredibly liberal city like gay
rights like
party like the elite was in a collective
happiness yeah but 95 of the people
were most likely thinking you're [ __ ]
crazy because they were all farmers yeah
and was it actually was it was the dawn
so we were moving from an agrarian
culture right korean society
into the industrial age that was this
was the evening or the
eve so the evening the eve of the the
the industrial age yeah
so but unfortunately in that industrial
age a lot of the people
who were needed in the in the agrarian
age
were redundant if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about tech instead of non-stop yelling
check out our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification
bell